can we get your reaction to the very sad
news about such a moment
I'm absolutely shocked to hear this news
it was only recently that we heard that
he was am stepping down for health
reasons and not returning I never worked
with uh Sir Jeremy personally but I know
many colleagues and colleagues in
government who did and they were all in
all of his abilities he was a very
impressive individual he was very gifted
he worked under many different
governments governments of all colors
and he was someone who Prime Minister's
often looked to and trusted to get
things done he was in the words of a
friend of mine he was an amazing person
you could always find a solution to to a
tricky problem and many of the things
that have happened in this country
happened because of him it's a it's a
huge loss to the country it's a huge
loss to the government it's very sad
news and thoughts go to his family thank
you and now of course we'll have more on
that news later on in the program but I
also do want to talk to you about Brett
Slater
now you're somebody of course who you
vote to leave the European Union and we
can have a little look at something that
you previously said as an economic
liberal I want to see Britain trading
more freely around the world so would
she be happy then with a customs
arrangement that limited Britain's
ability to trade around the world
well the Prime Minister's repeatedly
said that we'd be leaving the customs
union so whatever sort of deal we get it
should be something that allows us to
become a more global outlook sort of
trading more globally with the rest of
the world and that's the outlook that we
want and there's reports of course that
the the backstop if you like is going to
be an agreement that the whole of the
United Kingdom stays in a customs union
with EU I mean is that something that
you would accept I think if I still
think it's a it's it's speculation at
the moment I don't see how given the
promises the Prime Minister has made
that that's something that could be on
the table even temporarily it depends on
what is meant by temporarily if it's
something indefinite then absolutely not
so you'd have to see some kind of dates
if you like in order to
I think that's what I think that I think
that's certainly what the government has
been working to but ideally wouldn't
even get to get to that and now moving
on to other issues and you are somebody
who said that you want to try and change
the image of the Conservative Party to
show you that it's not just about stuffy
aristocrats and older Tony um's do you
think the concept is have an image
problem yes and no I certainly think
that a lot of people have view this
Furio type of us which is not actually
what we're like and it's more about
showing what the Conservative Party
really is it's people like me it's you
know people like my next-door neighbor
Robert how fern James cleverly pretty
Patel this is a very sort of broad
diverse group of people and we were
representative of the vast majority of
people who vote conservative but sadly
when you know when I knock on doors
people think I didn't think the
Conservatives came in you know this sort
of shape and size and color and so on
that you said that you've been mistaken
for labour and yes it's one more
disappointing things what sort of
happened there well I let people know
that you I'm definitely not lever and
and I think that veil pleasantly
surprised that they usually pleasantly
surprised because they tend to think
that Rhys is such a big factor in how we
vote in my hope that my having this role
goes some way to challenge that yeah and
because there is a bit of an issues in
there with BM e voters in the
Conservative Party mean if we look at
the last few elections in 2017 only 19%
of BM e voters went for the Conservative
Party compared to 73% going for labour I
mean why do you think it is that the
Conservative Party is a turn-off for
these voters um there are many many
reasons some of them are historical so
if you look at the countries that many
people from ethnic minorities tend to
come from emigrate from you know I speak
as a first generation immigrant myself
they tend to be socialist country so
socialist politics is more normal so we
already have a huge barrier in terms in
terms of them actually showing people
there are the types of politics that
that you can do so that's the first one
the second one is that other parties
labor in particular really labor has
been better historically at going out to
you know doing outreach with these
voters and that's something that the
party is doing a lot of I mean do you
think that some of the issues are the
allegations for example around
Islamophobia in the concept of party I
mean the former chair Barry r/c said
it's very widespread but it's being
effectively ignored I mean is it
something that the concept I party need
to take more seriously I completely
disagree with the barrenness varsity's
view on that we take every single
allegation of Islamophobia seriously and
where we do find party members or people
who hold positions and local government
doing things we tend we suspend them we
investigate why is it the most Muslim
councillor person's called for an
inquiry I don't think the Muslim Council
of Britain is um is an organisation that
would look very favorably on the
conservative party anyway so I think
that there's a probably a political
motive there when I have looked at the
cases that we've talked about I've seen
strong investigations which had been
done fairly and there are many people in
the party who are Muslims who don't
recognize the allegations about sis Lama
phobia okay and now you are in charge of
candidate selection a recent report by
the Fawcett Society found that female
parliamentary candidates are still
facing barriers to entry getting asked
questions for example about what the
husband thinks about them running to be
an MP about what they're gonna be doing
about childcare and is that something
that you have personally experienced or
is it something that you're worried
about you know other women experiencing
no I've never had personal experience of
that and I think those things used to
happen quite a while ago but the story
still still go on do you think maybe
it's putting off yes it is definitely
it's definitely something that puts
people off and we let them know that
it's actually not like that anymore but
the real issue we have is women not
wanting to come forward because they're
worried about personal abuse they don't
like this with the toxic atmosphere of
politics at the moment there are so many
barriers that women have in terms of
coming forward and a lot of it is
actually the way that we we approach
these and these types of jobs we like to
think that we must be qualified or
overqualified before we go for them men
don't and if you look at how long it
takes it typically takes a woman about
two years to make the decision to do
that with the men I say it's about 48
hours to a week and that alone is
responsible for there being
so many more men than women coming
forward you see women have a harder time
on social media then you're talking
about the abuse and the I think they
tend to attract more attention simply
because they're not as many women in
politics it's the same way if you're an
ethnic minority as well so I have loads
of followers for instance I have no idea
they are where they come from they're
not necessarily constituents and then if
you represent a party that's in
government people have a lot more to be
on so you're saying you're getting that
kind of abuse racist perhaps excess
abuse and social and I did to be honest
Sophie I actually don't check my Twitter
unless it's someone I follow I didn't
see the messages so I don't feel that
way but I know a lot of other MPs do and
quite a few have have come off it as
well probably quite as sensible and now
to sort of finish the interview I want
to talk a bit about your life because
you're not the typical member of
parliament shall we say and you used to
carry a machete to school you have to
tell me a bit more about this story what
was that about oh yes so this is what I
grew up with this when I was living in
Nigeria I grew up in in Nigeria and I
went to a state boarding school most
people go to them it's a federal
government school and you have to bring
in we were owned equipment we had to cut
the grass ourselves we had something
called a manual labor everyone had to do
you know it's a pretty hard work every
day and you cut grass with the machete
so we had I think I was telling a story
about how knife quarum is more than just
the availability of weapons it's also
attitudes and I was talking about how
everyone in school had a machete and we
didn't use them to attack each other it
was a lot more to what was going on in
terms of crime but yes that baddest case
it was under my bed
you've also previously spoken about what
you've described as the arrogance of
white men thinking they can save Africa
what did you mean by that
oh this is very historical crate Sophie
if this must have been in about the mid
Maltese and I remember getting very
frustrated about people and it isn't it
isn't directed at white men certainly
not but I do think that there is a
savior complex for people who don't
actually understand very much about
Africa I mean don't you talk about
people like Bob Geldof for example I'm
not naming any names but I do think a
lot of the solutions to the problems of
Continent need to come from that
continent I don't think it's going to be
people from here who you can ride in on
a white horse and save them and save
everybody there and I do worry about
that savior complex and just finally and
you know when you were kind of growing
up in Nigeria you know you've spoken
about living without electricity having
to fetch water in a bucket from a mile
away
yeah how do you think that experience
has defined your politics now oh it's at
the very heart of it and I I think
growing up in a third-world country has
really shaped me and makes me think
about everything from the context of
what's it like for other people and and
how can we make things better so things
like energy security for example when
you've lived with blackouts you get very
paranoid about you know what are we
doing is there going to be enough energy
enough fuel how are we managing it
looking at balancing that with them
dealing with issues around climate
change and so it affects that it affects
for instance how I think about identity
politics growing up in a place where I
couldn't stand for election the way I
have now in the UK in Nigeria I remember
talking about it with a politician for
me why was that he said oh well you
can't just stand being away where you
live you have to go to you know where
your family's from and my grandparents
are from a place that they moved away
from there in the 40s or 50s and I've
never been there and he said that's
where you'd have to go to have to go to
that particular town to stand for
election whereas now I stand
you know I'm elected in Saffron Walden
which was a place that I didn't have any
connections to I was a Londoner and B
just liked ent do I gave and they said
this is the person they want to
represent very different from Nigeria
model yeah and I think I think that's
amazing what we have here the people
don't judge you about where you're
coming from but about what you can do
okay